wunderbar ja wenn ich jetzt mal die
masken das den einfach eine nehmen und
dann probiert sie doch schon mal an
augenmasken für das bevorstehende blind
date und das im wahrsten sinne des
wortes denn die männer und die frauen
die sich hier gleich begegnen werden
sollen sich nicht sehen sondern durch
riechen tasten und spüren näher kommen
dann sind wir bereit dann warten wir
jetzt matti frauen und dann geht's los
willkommen die reporter spezial ehre sei
gott und lebensmittel und um die frage
wo irgendwo auftaucht und office oder
und europa wird die phase zwischen 40
und 50 das ist für viele bezirke ein
prüfstein
es gibt dir die drive mal dass ein tick
wo sich tour ging es hat wohl einfach
weitermachen oder andere wo plötzlich
offen sind für neues und die treffe ich
90 männer schon parat macht und frauen
sind auch in anderem licht im sales of
speed dating der wenn sich mann und frau
mit allen sinnen kennen lernen
eine der teilnehmerinnen ist petra
frisch verliebt ist sie neuen
bekanntschaften dennoch nicht abgeneigt
monica ist sogar in begleitung ihres
mannes zum dayton gekommen
werder begann ich frage mich hat dir die
person voller haltloser die debeka knick
forderten strecke einmal ufermann stück
voller hat strecke schnitt und wann zu
festgefahren hatten du dich wirklich
wieder die person erinnere ist einfach
nicht viel machen da rauschen super
league machen den strick schweigen
das ist doch liegt idee also nicht viele
sätze ja nicht nehmen auch selbst hier
nach was für mich war es klar selbst
sammeln vorstellig
mein job ist es die mich an lange nicht
dass das finde ich gut michael reitz
form also also über teils in eine völlig
fremde lernen und dann einfach gespürt
dass ich das auch für mohamed also das
komme darum das interesse sei reizvoll
warum günther und ganz ehrlich weil ich
mich damit noch nie beschäftigt hat mit
anderen dating sachen ich habe davon
gehört von dem central speed dating und
dachte das ist mein ding das finde ich
cool und alles andere weiß immer so und
das will ich lieber nicht ausprobieren
da habe ich zu viel stress gerade mit
der optik und sozusagen heilig gucken
leute an und dann wichtig die weg oder
werde weggewischt
auf gar keinen fall ich spiele klavier
ich bin auch ich bin eine partnerschaft
und ich bin einfach gespannt was es halt
für neue war geht liegt das erfahre und
strafe will um das grundsätzlich ist
einfach gern mitglied connector und das
ist eine neue ebene
ja und da können wir noch dann darfst du
langsam die hände vor die rausstrecken
und in die verbindung eingehen so
miteinander ankommen erstmal erst mal
die hände einfach halten und rein spüren
wie sich das anfühlt diese hände
setzt seinen tastsinn und seinen
geruchssinn ein um herauszufinden wie
dir diese frage fällt
wen kann ich gut riechen wer fühlt sich
richtig gut an mit wem matches das
gegenüber mit allen sinnen erfahren
darum geht es am central speed dating es
gibt anlässe für singles aber auch für
paare für hetero- homo- oder bisexuell
für monogam oder polar [ __ ] lebende wie
die teilnehmenden an diesen event hier
petra die zweifache mutter führt
liebesbeziehungen mit mehreren männern
gleichzeitig
[Musik]
einer von petras partnern ist armin
in abstimmungen wie viel partner
hersteller als fesche pforten der
neueste band habt wer noch unter zwei
mit die namentlich mit namhaften festen
partner sind die zwei hinter es ist mir
sowieso act fehler womit die tiefe
kerben und und der armen sondern einfach
durch die leichtigkeit anna sophie ja
oft auch wie viel sind jetzt im system
mit massig nur 40 beinhaltet die bezirke
jetzt noch etwas schnee
das sagt ein kollege listen der
verschiedenen die verbindung petra so
mini partner meistertitel mit verbringen
weiß momentan und deren blick sich
weniger häufig nicht kapazitäten folgt
zitat alle gliedmaßen gesehen
[Musik]
wie du deine polyamorie leben kannst
auch wenn du noch in einer monogamen
beziehung lebst
dass ich so weit der haupttitel
bezüglich um polio modi wie wir in
sieben schritten unsere beziehungen in
achtsamkeit geöffnet
doch darf sich früher frauen und betete
mit 39 glauben muss barroso automobil
auftrieb erhalten
bisher peter und armin bei der
gestaltung ihrer neuen homepage
sie bieten coachings an für menschen die
ihre beziehung öffnen und neu delhi am
ohr leben wollen
das ist einfach das klappt betitelte
will ich nicht gewusst das ist normal
das hat nicht schon früher york von also
mit 20 jahre 20
bis ich dann da bin und mich dann in
monogamie situation begeben und dann
wieder gemerkt hab dich escort nötig
laut nyt mich lappe und das ist so ganz
tief dann plötzlich ohne hose und dann
ich möchte zwar sehr einfach jetzt
beginnt das war sicherlich auch bereits
mit dem team sehr sehr leid also familie
der ex partner janko oder und ein
bisschen oder andere gang was hat das
ganze ja also ziemlich barriere
mittring und hat einen wirklich mühsam
ich hoffe er findet frauke weiß nicht in
frage dass ihr unterschreiten sie als
probiert werden social fundamente
ausprobiert weil ich mit etc
als ich 19 war das ist ganz klar mit der
neue partnerin das ist sehr schöne
beziehung mit denen zwei und ich bin
nach zwölfjähriger ehe hat sich petra
von ihrem mann getrennt und lebt nun
offiziell polyamorie mit armin ist sie
seit gut einem jahr zusammen die richtig
wichtig regel haben hier die sexualität
dass man sich selber sechs platzieren
und offenheit also dass kommunikation
mit genau das ist so eine regel haben
[Gelächter]
gemeinsam ihr brauchst ist weil paula
monika [ __ ] funktionierte auf vertrauen
und dadurch wissensdurst wenn ich als
friede weiß kann ich auf dem mixtape
entscheiden
und wenn sie mit kundenkarte wird wohl
nicht daran ich mich nicht entscheiden
was ich das gar nicht
das vordach hinein aber nicht mit ob sie
ersparte geld zu versorgen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
dies erlaube als das im moment
wahnsinnig viel sehens ist und träume
auf die polymere kleid wird und die
offene beziehung und schwieriger am ganz
danke ich wirklich der aufwand wenn man
es recht unter dem motto funktionieren
aber man muss nur mehr leisten
mir ist auch mit neue erlebnis und neue
herausforderungen konfrontiert
jede monogame beziehung nicht gekannt
das teile für paare ereignis den
geburtstag also das vorrecht das tun die
zur sache unromantisch logistisch aber
polyamorie war kann nicht die
diskussionen
petra und armin sind mit bernhard
verabredet petras zweiten festen partner
peter und bernhard haben sich erst
kürzlich ineinander verliebt
dass ich wichtig bin ferner trafen
jahres zu windig stattfindet also eine
logische fehler von mir dass intelligenz
namen verdient haben und bereits jetzt
trägt das wirklich dir
staubli zwischen jemand darüber erst
einmal jetzt 2
es ist ziemlich zehn fehler und zu wenig
speed und es verbindet alles mitgenommen
bremst auslösen slogan ist so wie wenn
es eine paste musik ist sache war nicht
mehr besucht und dann absage und trete
damit sie trotz nötiger das damals
[Musik]
wochenend- und panzer gesehen
[Gelächter]
es ist wichtig zu verstehen ist
[Musik]
was gibt dir der orden wurde bernhard
dirr mitgeht und umgekehrt ist die frau
wirklich durch seit ich werde weniger
behindern
[Gelächter]
bender gibt man das so viel die
lebendigkeit look right so dass das
sieht man dass verfolger inter verliert
bei den s&p geht ist natürlich so dass
mit dem business travel show auf große
resonanz
die hand so wunderschöne erotische und
sinnliche und er wunderbar sexualität
und ich jedem wünschen kann ja nicht
weißt was du sagst daß es ist ein
hausdach zu haben suite gehäufte werk
entstehen und andrea mit ii bezieher und
mit tieren oder das einfach dass das
dorf entsteht das für die bahn hat jetzt
dazu das ist nicht zu hause ist
das ist vorbei und die sind zum teil der
nahrung mit gange
[Musik]
ja dann könnt ihr euch jetzt auch wieder
in den händen fassen eine hand oder zwei
hände zurück beim speed-dating uns
zeichen geben ob die begegnung gefallen
hat und noch mal als kleine erinnerung
superbikes machen in dieser runde meist
am meisten sinn weil er so viele sachen
zusammen kommen
per handzeichen geben die teilnehmenden
an wie ihnen die begegnung gefallen hat
die organisatorinnen halten die
ergebnisse nach jeder runde fest
aufgrund ihrer eigenen enttäuschenden
erfahrungen mit den gängigen dating
plattformen und events wollen die beiden
frauen mit ihren anlässen ein
gegenprogramm zu kinder und co bieten
gut liebe männer dann dürft ihr euch
wieder an den händen fassen und rotiert
eine matte nach rechts
was liebe dir für bezüge also ich liebe
monogamie bezirk jetzt und falls man das
bedürfnis haben auf andere lied dann
wenn man darüber rede mir redet dann
wenn es aktuell lässt man dafür ähnlich
sieht sondern und in die ganze sache die
außerhalb das an die bedürfnisse dass
das angesprochen werden
ja es ist das ist statistisch elite mega
hemmschwelle wenn sie merkt hier
eigentlich die schlimmste fandré aber
ich habe nur angst dass ansprache will
schon auf dem iphone
und ich glaube das ist die schönste
warum setzen die offenheit des urlaubs
offene beziehung ja genau ich monogam
gestartet und mindestens your back oder
einzelne studieren und dann ist das
risiko einfach aussieht sagt okay und
will weg des probierens man mir dann
aber danach knecht und dann wieder dann
heiko ist dass ich es eigentlich stimmig
auf mich dass wieder sozialarbeit und
dass mir die freiheit war meine hand
jetzt nicht einfach wieder wandte und
bürger auch vor zu hieß es weiter geht
lasalle die letzten begegnungen los und
machte ich nochmals für den neue
personen die vor dir stets mit der jetzt
das erste mal in kontakt treten wird
offene pci bleibe der polyamorie
vielleicht ist das nicht gemacht hat
monogamie und das wäre ein standort wie
sie höchstens rote auf das thema auch
einmal auf jeden fall noch mal zurück
aber zuerst einmal wissen wie er sich
wenn er langjährige bce großen anbricht
und wenn man plötzlich die miete vom
labour wieder allein dasteht
[Musik]
was hat jetzt der ihn für gültig im
moment sind so einfach katharina rieger
erinnerungen an gute zeiten schlechte
zeiten als abschnitt ja aber es ist
vorbei aber ich rechne da jemand ist der
ausbruch durch den schritt nie aber ich
glaube langsam wieder aktiv
mein programm übernommen naja
wahrscheinlich special ich persönlich
nicht abschließend gesagt werden
beerdigung aufgebahrt
er wird sterben ist einfach wir fertig
definitiv abgeschlossen
für mich ist oslo verein selber haben's
geschafft ich glaube es ist ein
mächtiger cocktail von gefühlen auch wut
versagen auch zu realisieren
man hat den menschen so ganz anders
gesehen und wie es jetzt ist drei
menschen drei unabhängige
scheidungsfälle die nichts miteinander
zu tun haben
rolf wurde nach 30 jähriger beziehung
von seiner frau verlassen
auch die erwachsenen söhne sind
unterdessen ausgezogen
eine zäsur mitten im leben fühlt sich
rolf zurückgelassen
allein
sie sollten im fall defekter richtig ja
natürlich muss dann wiederum geweckt hat
ja einzig das zwischenzeitlich noch mal
jährte tja da sei schon mehrfach ganz
klar aber straflos wieder traurigkeit
aus aber es sagt irgendwann eine
unbeschwertheit von früher und das ist
auch so ähnlich ergangen ist ja so wie
es wahrscheinlich ganz viele dachten
[Musik]
doris feld beim schauen ihres hochzeits
videos auf wie unbekümmert glücklich ja
fast schon naiv sie als junge frau ins
eheleben ging voller hoffnung
eine liebeshochzeit aber das leben
verändert einen dient elite verändert
sich die hat sich daniela b verwenden
das sicher mehr alltag geworden
es ist sicher wieso und ziel erreicht
hochzeit ist gewesen und jetzt wo kommen
die neuen ziele und dann irgendwann
familie und das hat ihm auch keiner
vorher gesagt was herausforderungen ist
und was für ein spagat ss alle
bedürfnisse unter einen hut zu bringen
soll ich mir auch x-mal über leid oder
was irgendwas falsch gemacht was er
nicht dazu bietet dass es geklappt hat
aber mich sonntags trotz einer mitmach
und heizungswärme ich mir dann halt
wieder als audi und am schluss
partnerschaft polit dufte strikt dann
ist weiß noch ein zeitdruck zurücktreten
müsste wo sie bauer
aber ich sage so jetzt sind mir wichtig
aber und auch eine schülerin
fast jede zweite ehe wird geschieden die
durchschnittliche ehedauer liegt bei 15
jahren beziehungskiller nummer eins das
zeigen studien ist der alltagsstress die
muße für gemeinsame augenblicke bleibt
in langzeitbeziehungen häufig auf der
strecke
es wird zu wenig gute zeit miteinander
verbracht oder vielleicht jetzt sieht wo
man mit fern und verbringt hier ist
überhaupt nicht inspirierend also ich
meine in netflix und serie b watching in
ehre denn wenn das alles ist was bynum
auch das haben wir sagen aus guter lage
machen oder mit kollege und mann
verpasst die einfach so hey ich habe
mich verändert 50 mio aud verlassen
müsste sondern lieber still und da bin
ich mal wieder auf deren bequemlichkeit
von bekannten auch tobias ließ sich vor
kurzem von seiner frau scheiden was ihm
schwer fiel
gerade auch der beiden kinder wegen auch
wenn diese bereits teenager sind
doch daraus wie sie sich das gewohnt
sind sagt und humorvoll und ja das ist
ja schon 25 jahre waren tobias und seine
ex frau ein paar schöne zeiten wie er
sagt doch gegen ende schlich sich immer
stärker werden der wunsch ein im leben
noch einmal neu anzufangen hat sie dann
ab dem punkt dass neda beratung von
andere art und ich schätze sie nach wie
vor als guter freund und
partnerunternehmen gemeinsame kinder
das ist nach wie vor für mich selber
wichtig ist aber die romantische liebe
sie
[Musik]
die bezirke wohl noch einige jahre seine
antwort gibt es fast dass bauer nicht
auf sexualität oder der zustand von der
sexualität müssen sagen happy aus nidda
rolle gespielt
minister bewusst sie das kräftige
bezirke sind zum beispiel da die ganze
suche nach vertrautheit noch entspannt
nach komfort noch möglich das sind zum
beispiel für sexualität
ob die leidenschaft vermisst die
sexualität gewissen punkt da sind
das war mir sicher dass es in der
beziehung nämlich echte fründe sie
vertraut die sie für alles füreinander
also eigentlich sehr schöne bezirks wird
das sind nicht unbedingt wahnsinnig
attraktiv für die gesagt wenn es jetzt
um die nächste heisse sexualpartner
magath und mir dort zum teil eigenen
unglück
das ist nicht nur die böse auch nützlich
sondern auch und wohlig karten der
bequemlichkeit womöglich übertrieben
oder aber nicht ausgleichen
zur abnutzung gesellen sich in
langzeitbeziehungen häufig streitereien
und konflikte so auch bei doris trotzdem
haderte sie mit der entscheidung sich
von ihrem mann zu trennen
aus schlechtem gewissen den drei
töchtern die vertraute umgebung
wegzunehmen
es gibt sehr viele frauen in meinem
alter die eben das nicht gemacht haben
und ich glaube viele hätten es
vielleicht wenn sie ganz ehrlich zu sich
selber sind auch gern gemacht weil sie
in einer beziehung leben die absolut
nicht konstruktiv ist einfach gewohnheit
ist oder auch man sich gar nichts mehr
zu sagen hat aber auch eine große große
abhängigkeit von ihrem partner ist und
man sich deshalb auch nicht traut weil
man diese angst hat was danach wie
weiter trotz anfänglicher trauer sei die
scheidung für die gesamte familie eine
erleichterung gewesen aufatmen der druck
ausgelöst durch die permanente
missstimmung sei weg dennoch hoffen die
mädchen mama und papa würden wieder
zusammenkommen
simons r traurig und ich weiß auch an
den tag ist dann wirklich so war haben
alle geheult
alle fünf bis dahin ihres gar nicht sein
das hat meine ex-frau kommuniziert und
das ist sehr schwierig zu kommunizieren
ja nein das habe ich nicht warum
sind wir wieder beim thema spiel wieder
ja man steht dann wieder als geliebte
vater da hatte ich das gefühl das ist
immer von lukas und schwärzte von der
fußball liebling der geister
fußballerisch sind wieder da neuburger
schlafen immer viel da sehr
sarkastischen apparat weitere große dem
jedem haushalt sollte will er wirkt ja
ganz am anfang meint nord das anderen
ort an anne will ich habe nicht
geschafft hat hat sie sich heimisch
bekanntenkreis dann aber wieder als zwei
personen kann ich dann auch einen alten
fabrik oder appstore verbieten mit ich
mitkomme für rolf eine wichtige stütze
seine nachbarin sie und ihr mann sind
rolf stets zur seite gestanden
[Musik]
das handbuch die den oman deshalb bat
noch eine rolle der weiß nimmt das neu
geschaffene tores aschenbecher alle die
mal heben die enorme das alles braucht
gott und die genaue immer genau gewusst
wie dringlich dass es ist ja dass ich
bitte die situation also wirklich angst
um dich aber sie waren normale bezirke
partnerin ich spiele fester überzüge
dass das wieder gut und werde
überzeugung dass man nur schaffen ist
mareike sie sicher ans ziel ja dass man
in der liga bleibt und ja doch dass man
eben zweisamkeit mit der ligen fallen
und alt werte ja es gibt immer noch
frauen ja dass das casino auf jeden fall
[Musik]
krise verletzungen und der wunsch neue
jahr 2000 das brauchen jetzt gerade
besucher erlebt aber während sich andere
trend entziehen immer noch zimmer und
ist dass wir bei oder wird auch
bequemlichkeit dass wien red
[Musik]
katharina und kasper psychotherapeutin
und musiker sie verliebten sich aus
teenager es folgten hochzeit und drei
kinder
mittlerweile sind die beiden 30 jahre
ein park jetzt genau vor 30 jahren sehr
schmal tötet nicht leicht ich sie mit
dem kauf bleibe zu wenig reparieren was
ich sagen kann ich bin froh und dankbar
man hat die anfangs tipp für euch danken
hat immer so eine faszination für
innovative und forsten auslöste im
business-look kraft beim islamic und
ganz richtig verstanden
händler die faszination auf ihren
[Musik]
angesagt oder wie es heißt ja der bar le
und er hat die bosse zu perfekt zahnhals
ich alles klischee spiel sehe ich
überhaupt nicht so
und die faszination kann ich nun das
spiel kontrolliert und so von den augen
für mich ist immer noch ich lieber
nichts bezahlen
ich finde dass das mich motiviert das
alles ist extrem frisch dass ich schon
immer da und klärt für heute moment ganz
trocken hält sie sprühen
warum
schick wichtig sein kann auch nicht
sagen sie mir absurd und unruhig sommer
ausloten
diese grenze kennen lernen und mir hat
es ja vor jungen nach mittel jung nach
älteren mittelalter entwickeln und das
braucht viel umbrüche und und termine
haben wir uns zum teil neu erfinden und
das hat eben schon so weit springt dann
wahrscheinlich mit verursacht
diesmal frage im nachhinein wie willst
du damit umgang aber du von trusteer
überhaupt also wohl nicht klüger du bist
dir sicher dass du bei dem momentan
nicht gemerkt
das heißt für mich jetzt gucke ich wen
absterben würden und das hatte ist an
beiden ufern finden sich selber und dann
dort aus haben sie haben können ist eine
umgekehrte weg sie erfahre ich dass
katharina eine andere beziehung hat
selbstmitleid ist wahnsinnig groß und so
kommt der gegner ebene wie sich dann
quasi zusammen kriegen ein physisch
psychisch rückseite eine gutschrift also
mitte zwanzig und das hat mich und das
akzeptiere ich akzeptiere mega schwierig
sind und das hat dann aber wieder die
ansieht braucht worauf ich mir über das
schnurren und diskutieren und die
auseinandersetzung gesagt lang und ich
ja noch immer das ist das hat sogar ganz
viele trennen sich
warum die frau kachelmann falsch wie das
wunder also wenn man denkt dass man sich
alles zurück meldet sich und ruhe und
wird und so und ich erinnere mich haben
acht liche diskussion einschlafen
hinzugekommen zermürbende gesprochen und
jetzt nochmal weil zur normalerweise und
das komme will ich so um die 30 aber
immer noch hinter sich wird es alles
viel schwieriger
also von dth man sagt das hatte ich ein
poster zur einheit auf die häuser so auf
die aufnahme sich gelohnt und die
diskussionen und immer wieder angemerkt
hat das eigentlich nicht nicht zerstören
dass das hat dann aber immer wieder
kraft zu tanken und ich gerne große wie
eine zeitlose jetzt ist patrick soll wo
altig lässige so erlebte die krise
überstanden hat rihs klar sie sind immer
noch zwei mal was ich dass ich es liebe
oder ist es bequemlichkeit und noch
keine reue getroffen hat das gefühl
langsamer sie ist das gegenteil von
bequemlichkeit hatte bis komfortabel sei
aber eben nicht nur
oder essig wie beides dass ich es schon
megacool das war einfach so dass sich
abstützen
aber das eben nicht nur einfach so kann
man sich mit krieg sondern jahren
abstützen und das nachdem das ist aber
tisch also als paar im mittleren
lebensalter 31 beide pulverig stream
engagiert sind
die meisten beschäftigen ich hoffe die
mit dem dichter alltag so schön
entspannt
momentanes kreieren also dass das ist
natürlich extrem effizient für die reds
massaker entwickelt wie man ich hörte
dass toronto raptors die die augen
sollten sie wo immer ein halber tag
[Gelächter]
und das als man es entnimmt
es gibt da die trennt sich noch krise es
gibt aber andere partie entscheidet sich
für das neues bezirks modellen auf ihre
politik bezeichnet mehrere menschen
und was grundsätzlich ist die zu tief um
die form die frage warum und wann es die
verbraucht dann kann ich mir das
vorstelle
ob er im bezirk so jetzt ist zustand
jetzt kann ich es mir überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dass dank dem sind klug sind
kann man das nur gut auf das ist
wesentlich das wort wie die reds eine
gute nachfordern
komisch aber ich bin die nötig war zwar
immer wieder russischen armee und noch
diese 700 jungen können
bush dem mikro und und sich also alle
möglichen optionen und und ford hat es
gut in afrika sache unspektakulär uncool
und und ich finde dass hatten extreme
werde mich jetzt dass menowin auf das
beste in dieser sache zu werden
[Musik]
beim speed dating für polyamorie kommt
man sich unterdessen tanzen nähe
[Musik]
die meisten hier sind monogam in ihr
beziehungsleben gestartet sie kennen die
tücken einer zweierbeziehung die
abnutzung routine es passieren
seitensprünge und das nicht zu knapp
die partnerschaft öffnen und mehrere
verbindungen gleichzeitig eingehen macht
dieses beziehungsmodell glückliche mies
fazit ist dass die meiste manche
schlicht und einfach nicht bezirks
kompetenz hand oder ihrem bezirk schon
bewiesen
um wirklich ein ösv nichts machen will
es braucht neue kommunikation es wucht
nomi investition es braucht noch mehr
abstimmung
es braucht auch als dienst richtig
romantisch es muss nur im sinn von einer
großzügigen vergabe von einem
schwierigen moment und bewiesen dass oft
abziehen und uns im gegen streifen seine
augen wieder ans licht langsam zu
gewinnen mit geschlossenen lidern und
dann darfst du jetzt deine arten wieder
öffnen
die teams kannst du dich einlassen auf
diese begegnung es ist die letzte runde
nun dürfen sich die frauen und männer
zum ersten mal in die augen schauen
auch monika ist offen für neue
bekanntschaften die dreifache mutter ist
seit gut 20 jahren polar [ __ ] unterwegs
sie nimmt gemeinsam mit ehemann chris an
diesem anlass teil wie die beiden lieben
das sehen wir gleich im anschluss des
datings das war die letzte begegnung von
heute abend ihr habt es geschafft mit
wem hat es tatsächlich gemanagt
die genaue auswertung wird per mail
nachgeliefert kann das operieren und
musst du ich habe das ist so tief dass
ich bin verwirrt da darf wird abrufen
positive achtzehnter ist erfrischend die
geselligkeit die reine sinnlichkeit ihm
zugeordneten pfunde und meine
dankbarkeit gegenüber dass hier schafe
hält
[Musik]
stets unterwegs zu monika und chris die
beide heraus ob im speed dating klinik
lernt und sie hat sich als wahre
entschieden zu 70 jaroslawl und ich
besonders gespannt was das für sie als
familie bedeutet vor allem für ihre
[Musik]
monika und chris technische redakteurin
und geschäftsführer eines unternehmens
als teenager verliebt später geheiratet
drei kinder mittlerweile seit 31 jahren
ein paar
die erste frage gestellt und ich seit
ich bleibe meiner familie es war keine
police lebt ja wieviel handy in otepää
zu genau wie würdest du hat zwei weitere
bezirke eine woche ungefähr sieht ja gut
zwei jahre intensiver mal weniger
intensiv und begründet bisher beide oder
frisch verliebt ja das ist aktuell in
jeder stand ja natürlich freundinnen
eine woche weiter weg wohnt wurden 300
kilometer entfernt und theoretischen sie
zwei audio und denn haben jetzt leben
jetzt frischen die zentralschweiz also
doch und doch schon einige szenen wie
heißt denn anfang ich kenne dort
übernahm sie teenager sind mit 18 uhr
das kreidler und sind die erste partner
gegenseitig sie für durch beide und das
ist schon öffentlich gar kreis thema sie
haben auch vier fünf jahren arbeitet
merkt es geht noch so viele interessante
liegt und und ist auch im luftraum die
horde und mirjam event eigentlich
zusammenblieben ist eine weitere
möglichkeit um händels klebten handys
umgang und den 16 trainer um anderes
mache das sind wir viel stärker durch
die durch miteinander schwätzen gold am
anfang ist es wirklich körperlich also
schrecklich darum gegangen die nutzung
spüre aber das hat sich dann stark
verändert
das ist für uns zumindest das mag für
andere war anders sie ist es zu wenig
also das ist ja aber vielleicht mit
einem citroen mir sehr sehr viel
miteinander dem geld kann ja was
passiert jetzt mit mir viel durch jetzt
zu finden bis anders als vorteile wo es
nur uns körperlich gegangen ist und den
himmels mit abstimmen stimmt es
eigentlich dass damals keine kriegskasse
um begriffe priorität das sicher hat
auch schon das waren die ersten
definiert als er rechnet sich einfach
wieder wachsen
das wäre ja auch mal so gar nicht
definiert aus irgendwelchen sperrte der
begriff keine klandt und noch viel
später eigentlich noch gar nichts
verlangen ist für das paar das noch
ausgeht gesellschaft das einfach mit
meter drüber
es ist konzept sagen wir so die übliche
konzepte sind monogamie oder den halter
bis fremdgeh und das bett toleriert über
das weiß man aber mit stil form also das
kennt merkt bis hart an die sache und
nicht wie ton oder wenn sie die grenzen
erreicht was zum beispiel ganz groß
ziemlich schlecht miteinander personen
ohne kondom das geht nicht das ist ganz
klar
es ist ja als 20 sie meiner peter hund
und ich bin weg was passiert denn da
also tabubereich man andere schon 17
das sind ziemlich bis das auch wo man
was man fast denken sich in ordnung um
den vermerk
und die teilnehmer von secured notes
christina und einfach um das geld sicher
gewinnträchtiger oder das thema ist mit
der permanent in hand der öffentlichkeit
doch mal auf also obst größere bezirke
wie man auch für das was ich meine ist
besteht also das sind alles so themen im
moment wirklich muss bedeutet ja dass
ich also ist vor einigen jahren
das habe ich keinen kontakt wenn wir das
nicht gemacht
ausnahme ist irgendwo weiter wächst wenn
du irgendwo in münchen oder in hamburg 7
städtisches temax sie aber drohne in
sozialen burkhard so dass man einmal
ganz kurz runter selbst hier aber es hat
ja ganz feste mit dem handy tatsächlich
endet und reifer welle dass das quasi so
theater frank schulz sparen
das gesamt und irgendwelche gründerzeit
sieht und dann quasi auf die kinder aber
nicht dass es zeit wird also das den
leben heute gott fremdgehen so wurde und
sie dann irgendwie weiß auch nachher hat
das schon mal gehört und der trend sich
eltern und eifrig passiert war überhaupt
kein thema also und eigentlich ist das
heutige sie warum wir die letzten spiele
wenn man einfach an wäre das kentern
stabiles umfeld und nicht irgendwelche
infos verluste denn ihnen ja
interpretiert wahlprogramm mit sind so
dass teenager das denn überhaupt
grundsätzlich mit studienkollegen
zumindest nicht bewusst
das ist für kritisches denn einfach sind
kollege für sotschi sind alte und schöne
hobby gekauft haben wir ganz besondere
aber ist ein fachkollege sie ja jetzt
also heißt wo man jetzt eine marktmacht
mit der freundin und stellte da ist und
der hund dort verschwinden und hier
damit das ist so haben wir gemacht haben
dass spannendes experiment wechseln also
wächst du sehen die partnerin kennen und
umgelenkt
ja und was ich kenne sie aber ja das ist
mir extrem wichtig wäre es ist ihm
wichtig ist und dann möchte ich nur so
weit dass ich es war nie versucht nie
versucht nein aber das ist eigentlich
braucht es ist ja entzieht frage weil
man einen anderen partner management wo
bin ich mehr oder das ist schwierig und
aber es hat auch ganz auf die
gefühlsebene ganz ganz viele
diskussionen und es hat also das ist
definitiv so dass ich wirklich im
prozess ein stadtteils vielleicht durch
himmel so zurückstecken der anderen aber
sind immer gute gespräche und das ist
wirklich bald fallen
monogamie bis 100 den ex manager
persönlich überzeugt dass der mensch von
natur her nicht monaten
das heißt aber nicht dass man mit
monogramm von 150 jahre lang monogramm
bleibt und glücklich damit ist respekt
vorm winter mit ein anderes miteinander
glücklich sind
aber wenn so statistiker zum hören dass
das 70 prozent wurden gedanken fremd
warum spielt und was 50 prozent schon
mal fremdgegangen sind und das heimlich
und den menschen das heimlich mit matter
denn eigentlich lacht österreich etwas
sonne ich mir die bezirks vor mir mit 14
also es ist gut dass das thema für die
von der metro wir denn dass ich mich
darüber freuen wenn sie ist gut wenn
sich jeder verliert die stehen wo sie
sich mal ihren mittagstisch und noch zu
ihrem flug auf dem quad core und durch
sie uns hat gerüchte dass der ganze ruhm
hätte jetzt im goldenen dreieck zwischen
einfach so mega sie sich freut
[Musik]
also ich hab einfach die und das lesen
und 40 grad an ja die liebe die er stolz
ist sehr stark zwischen ist nach der tat
um das leben so leben wie es für einen
selber bestimmt damit sich später mit
muss vorher vergleichs wesentliche
verpasst und das bringt uns zu unserer
nächsten sendung reporter spezial da
geht's ums leben im alter ist eine idee
dass mir ist die pflege bedürftiger ist
ausland exportiert zum mitspielen noch
ungarn das erkläre merkst du es einen
dick und exotik
[Musik]